Hey YouTubers! It's Charlie. So this is going to be my Game of Thrones episode two video.
Generally I think this episode is a lot more fun than episode one.
We're finally getting into some of the action of the season.
We get to see two big new locations
We also get to see some really fun familiar faces.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you haven't seen it yet.
And new round of the giveaway starts now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
It's for an HBO Now subscription.
So here we go starting with top five moments.
Number five: Arya goes to the house of Black and White.
If you remember the last time we saw The Titan of Braavos
It was when Stannis was going to get money from the Iron Bank.
I love how she laughs at the myth of The Titan.
You can tell that she doesn't care about faith. She's not a religious person.
I'll be interested to see how that changes, or if that changes
during her time with the Faceless Men.
I think they redid some of the CG for the city too, the city shots.
I mean obviously
We move through the camera. We move through the city so we see a couple of the different districts.
But the big wide CG shot just seems a lot nicer than the one during season four that we saw.
There's only ten episodes this season so I do think there are a lot of places in Braavos
that we just won't see. It's the same deal with Meereen. Like you only see certain places.
Cersei sent Mace Tyrell on a mission
to get more money from the Iron Bank so I do think that we'll see the Iron Bank again.
This character that she meets here looks like it's the Kindly Man from the books.
Although technically the first face that the Kindly Man shows her
is more of like a skeleton with scraps of skin hanging off of it.
He even has a worm crawling out of his eye that Arya has to kiss.
It's like her way of showing that she's not afraid.
In the episode I think her standing up to those street thugs kind of took the place of that thematically.
Did anyone else think it was curious that when she was saying her prayer outside on the steps,
she said The Mountain's name.
The whole list is actually very long so we're actually only hearing a small part of it.
And the mountain yes, who wonders what he's going to do with that head?
Probably just experiment on it. Maybe harvest it for stuff.
Because there's a bunch of Mountain related stuff
in the books, I'm going to wait till we see more of what the show is going to do.
I just don't want to get too crazy into spoilers so
please use spoiler tags if you want to talk about the Mountain or Robert Strong from the books.
On to number four: Pod and Brienne are like
every freaking chicken from season four.
I feel kind of bad for Brienne. It's like
every Stark child that she runs into just gives her the business and tells her to get out.
She did tell them the story of the smoke baby which was kind of fun.
You can't really tell if Littlefinger believes her.
I think he just wants to get rid of her. She's like a wild card that he just doesn't want to deal with.
It was kind of hard to tell what Sansa was thinking.
Maybe she just feels like Brienne reminds her of all the awful things that have happened to her family
and she just doesn't want to deal with it.
It's not that she likes Littlefinger
it's just that she's kind of grown comfortable with their situation and their
weird alliance that they have formed
and she doesn't want to deal with Brienne either.
As much as it seems like Sansa trusts Littlefinger,
I don't think that she does. I think that she's like slowly wising up
to the fact that she can't trust anybody.
Right now for her I think it's more of a "devil you know" situation.
She still has a lot to learn though before she can survive on her own, without Littlefinger's help.
It also didn't help Brienne's cause that she was wearing Lannister gear with a Valyrian blade.
But her speech was amazingly sincere.
Brienne is one of those heart breaking characters that's just
utterly sincere in everything she does but
just constantly gets kicked in the mud.
I know everyone is asking about Lady Stoneheart this season.
I still don't expect to see her. I think when she and Pod got separated
and Pod ended up in the river,
you could look at that as like an easter egg for Lady Stoneheart
just because we're right around that time in the books when she shows up.
I'm not expecting it but that doesn't mean it won't happen.
You guys can let me know whether you agree.
Do you think that Brienne is stupid for wanting to pursue Sansa to try and help her
even though Sansa wants to have nothing to do with her.
Should she just cut her loses and try to go back and serve with Jaime?
If she really wanted she could probably be named to The King's Guard by Tommen.
She'd have to do a little bit of convincing
and Cersei might not be super happy about it
but it seems like something that's never going to happen. Like total FanFic.
On to number three. Cersei and Jaime decide that Jaime is going to go to Dorne to get Myrcella.
If you're wondering who sent that message, who sent that threat
it's probably Ellaria Sand. She's the one that's
trying to start a war with the Lannisters.
They've changed a whole lot about the Sand snakes so I think
Ellaria Sand is Arienne Martell from the books
with a little bit of Obara Sand too.
We didn't see them in this episode so I'm just going to wait until next week to talk about
what the show is doing with the Sand Snakes.
Cersei tells Jaime that Myrcella is being kept at The Water Gardens.
The Water Gardens are where Prince Doran Martell has been hiding himself
just so his subjects don't see how bad his gout has gotten.
He just doesn't want them to see him as weak.
It's so much fun seeing Dr. Bashir Martell.
I'm a big fan of Alexander Siddig.
He said something really interesting about
his performance as Doran Martell.
He said he's basing a lot of the way he speaks his accent
on what Pedro Pascal did in season four.
It's just that inside the universe of the show
Pedro Pascal originated the Martell characters
so all the other actors that are member of his family, the Martell family,
have to take cues from that.
He's going to be a lot of fun. What I'm really hoping is
we see some of his character in season five
and he becomes a much bigger character in season six
the same thing that they did with Ellaria Sand.
Areo Hotah is going to be a lot of fun too.
I would say after Oberyn Martell vs. The Mountain the next biggest fight that I would like to see would be
Bronn vs. Areo.
I don't know if things will go down that way but if there's any two people
in Westeros that I'd like to see fight it would be those two.
On to number two. Daenerys tries to figure out what to do with the Sons of the Harpy.
So they capture one but then one of her freed slaves
executes him and she's forced to execute him in the name of justice.
It's this whole big thing about her trying to be more of a diplomat vs. a tyrant like her father.
It's funny that she doesn't know a lot about her father.
She says Viserys told her things but he probably didn't tell her the whole truth.
The Mad King. Lots of wild fire. Did not end well for anyone.
Barristan pretty much narrates Robert's Rebellion for her.
The rebellion didn't start so much because of Lyanna Stark being supposedly kidnapped,
by Rhaegar Targaryen even though I think that he didn't kidnap her in the first place.
What happened is The Mad King killed a bunch of nobels
and those nobel families banded together and started the rebellion.
Robert Baratheon was just the point man.
He was just the person everyone rallied behind.
So it wasn't the entire kingdom going to war over a woman being kidnapped.
It looks the Daenerys is facing the same situation
like things are going to descend to civil war inside Meereen.
We're only in episode two so expect things to escalate.
And isn't it funny how Barristan called out wild fire and then we see Drogon at the end of the episode.
He looks big enough to ride. Definately big enough to ride.
That would be a really quick way to solve all of her problems. Just roast all of the people yelling at her.
Finally my number one WTF moment:
Jaqen H'ghar reveals himself to Arya.
This is a really big departure from the books.
The Kindly Man, the person who Jaqen was masquerading as
people thought he might be Jaqen H'ghar.
but technically Jaqen H'ghar in the books is off on another mission doing something else on the other side of the world.
So I think we can assume they're cutting out pretty much all of the Citadel plot in season five.
If you don't know what I'm talking about, don't worry it doesn't matter for the show.
Jaqen H'ghar gonna teach her the way of the warrior. The way of the faceless warrior.
I'd say generally of all the running story lines right now that I'm most excited about
it's Jaime and Bronn headed to Dorne,
yay for Lollys. I'm so glad that Lollys is back. That was such a funny scene with Bronn.
And Arya learning to become a Faceless Man.
Just as a bonus we have to address Jon Snow becoming Lord Commander.
This should have been like a top six moments but anyways
Jon Snow Lord Commander right out of the books. Samwell
conspires with the other brothers to elect him.
I love how Maester Aemon was the one that cast the deciding vote.
I know a lot of you are disappointed that Jon didn't take Stannis' deal to become a Stark,
that will come back around eventually I think. It wasn't like a one time deal.
His sense of duty will continue to be tested.
Here's my big question for you guys: what was your favorite moment from the episode
and what do you think it's gonna take for Jon Snow to take Stannis' deal?
To legitimize him and become Jon Stark.
If Arya isn't going to be able to give up her past life and become
"no one" as Jaqen implied
do you think that the same thing is going to happen with Jon Snow?
Like they'll both end up choosing family over duty.
I mean I would really love to see that.
It'd be a very human choice to make.
Humans are flawed so as much as Jon wants to uphold the ideals that he believes in
he's probably going to make the emotional choice at a certain point.
All in all great episode. I know a lot of people were disappointed in the first episode just because
it moved a little slowly and they just spent so much time just setting stuff up
but now I feel like we're actually moving forward. We're moving all these plot lines forward.
Just a reminder I'll announce the winner in my Q&A tomorrow
so be sure to subscribe to get that if you haven't already.
All you have to do to enter the giveaway is be a subscriber and leave a comment. Nice and simple.
I haven't decided what my bonus video is going to be for next week so feel free to leave me a request in the comments.
Maybe something Dorne-ish if we're going to be seeing more of the Martells. Hopefully we'll see more of the Martells next week.
So while you guys wait for that Q&A to post you can click here to learn more about the Faceless Men of Braavos and the House of Black and White
and you can click here for my episode one video from last week.
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody lets high five. I'll see you guys tomorrow.